welcome back to glamour and filtered
hosted by me Josh Smith and today we are
joined by muddled activists turned
beauty mogul it's Charlie Howard's what
brought you to the public domain shall
we say is that you went on social media
you posted this thing on Facebook and
you called out your modeling agency at
the time for telling you these way and
you've been saying that beauty is a
subjective thing who you to tell me what
beauty is what would you want to say to
those people who told you that I feel
like you know at the time I was just so
ready to quit it anyway and I feel so
lucky that I've been able just to do
what I want to do at the size that I'm
at it really goes to show that you know
speaking your mind and sticking off
yourself doesn't have to be a bad thing
you're standing up there being such a
strong vocal voice for everyday girls
who are out there who have probably
gotten through the same things where
they're thinking I need to these way I
need to do this I need to do that well
you know what it is is that you think
it's just a modeling thing and it really
isn't it's like a global problem loads
of girls feel insecure about their
weight loads of girls have felt the need
to Dyer unnecessarily and actually I
actually think the fashion industry
holds a lot of responsibility in terms
of body image and the way that girls
view their bodies so you know we do have
to kind of listen to to women and and
the problems that they're facing what
kind of insane expectations have you
placed on your own body image at certain
times your life and how what kind of
extremes
have you gone to in order to try and
achieve that image va diet pills off the
internet back in the days when the
internet wasn't really regulated I
ordered I ordered these tablets that
would like to swell up in your stomach
to keep hunger at bay the 500 calorie
diet the thousand calorie diet the apple
a day diet like I mean every single diet
underneath the Sun I tried in order to
try and be thin even tea I was obsessed
with tea because I thought that if it
had two calories in it if I had more
than like two a day that was it was
gonna be fat was gonna wake up the next
day and just be ginormously fat but it
is literally what it does because when
you're engrossed in an eating disorder
which I was for like God ten years of my
life there's this voice in your head
that tells you that you can never be
thin enough so I had this ID
in my head that I had to be a UK size
six which is like a US size two if I
wasn't the US size to size six UK then
I'd failed and I just put all this
pressure on myself to be this body shape
and this is what that voice in your head
does is that it places so much
importance on the way that you look
which is just ridiculous how did you
overcome here a few different things so
I wrote the Facebook letter and by that
point I was like kind of ready just to
give modeling up and just go I just
can't do this anymore for the sake of my
own sanity I went to therapy which I'm
not ashamed about I think in the UK we
still have a bit of stigma around that
but I needed to go and that really
helped you know break down the OCD
because eating disorders are actually
obsessive compulsive threw away scales
threw away measuring tapes clay used to
carry a measuring tape around I actually
had two or three different measuring
tapes because I had to make sure that it
measured the same on each one because I
was that obsessed the scales I had to to
go upstairs and downstairs to make sure
that both of them measured the same it
was just it was just absolutely insane
and honestly like throwing away the
scales is my number one thing because
the minute you don't have that to look
at and those numbers to look at you stop
obsessing what is your relationship with
your self-critic like now because I mean
we all have a self-critic in our head
he's telling us one thing when they're
fair it's just about back if your mind
is literally just a thought we have and
this is what therapy taught me we have
millions upon millions of thoughts
rushing through our head every single
day and it's just a thought it's just
like a feeling it will go away and so
just remember that but that it's just
for a period of time that you're
thinking this just remember to keep
going and life is really difficult it's
not meant to be super high all the time
and I think I definitely had this
expectation throughout my life that
every single day should be happy and
unfortunately every day isn't going to
be a bundle of laughs like you you're
gonna have highs and lows people think
you've got it all together and they look
at social media and they think it's all
great I think as well I have a tendency
to look at other people's instagrams and
go oh my god she's doing so well oh my
god why is my life doing this I've got
this problem I've got this boy being
like this or whatever and actually it's
like calm down
Julia beans do you think you used to
place too much validation
on your body and now you swapped that
out and found validation from other
things you made these stories of like
women in their 50s who are like I hate
my body and like I lost so much weight
and I'm like I don't want to get to 50
years old and think I could have gone to
the beach that day but I decided not to
because I thought was gonna be too fat
in a bikini or you know I didn't want to
go on that date because I was worried
that that boy would think I was ugly or
something like that it's like no just
like just start believing in yourself
just look in the mirror every day now it
sounds really cringe look in the mirror
every day and tell yourself something
that you like about yourself and your
body and I guarantee you you will start
believing it where does your validation
come from now my friends our thing yeah
I get a lot of messages off girls going
oh you've helped me feel this way about
my body or this way and you're like oh
thanks what have you learned about
yourself through coming through air oh
my god how resilient I am and how
powerful your body is like I've abused
my body in so many different ways and
you're just like wow my body's still
stuck stuck by me through all of that
like that it's a really incredible thing
you talk quite a lot and you do pose
naked quite a lot I mean living for it
not naked but you know in your underwear
just do it just do it babes just do it
get it out do it for the gram but
because you were person who was so
wracked with not being sure about your
body and having all these questions
about your body how much is that taking
you in order to be able to pose and
underwear and feel confident yourself
for me personally it's really liberating
because I cannot tell you how much my
body used to disgust me from at the age
of like god 12 onwards or I would
literally look in the mirror every
single day for over ten years of my life
12 yeah about 10 to 12 years of my life
when you look in the mirror and you
detest yourself so much I couldn't look
at like like if I turn around the mirror
I would literally feel sick because I
had to cellulite at the age of 12 or 13
none of my friends had it I just feel so
insecure so actually put in like pick
some of my body on I find really
empowering but then you've got people
who of course think you know that as a
woman you can be in one category or the
other or you know you can be an author
but you can't possibly get in your Brown
underwear because
the two very conflicting and I think
what we should be teaching girls is
actually you can be both
that doesn't limit your abilities and it
shouldn't stop you from being an amazing
woman if you could sit yourself the you
that was going through the eating
disorders that was ordering these diet
pills on the internet and they were me
and they were sat here right now what
would you want to say to them what kind
of advice would you want to give that
person when you have eating disorders
nothing else matters and unless you want
to get better you're not going to get
better so that is a bit of a tricky
situation like if I go back in time of
course I'd rather not have had them but
I do think they're part of my story and
I think they've made me a stronger
person so that's me as a bit of tricky
one that one in the model industry today
is that anything that someone would say
to you that still surprises you or is
there things that happen that's still
surprised oh my god
so many things you know I'm still told
by girls that they're told to lose
weight all the time when there is
literally nothing of them it's just
ridiculous and it almost feels like now
we're going into a time where if you
have a voice and you're more of a
influencer model you're fine you're kind
of let off the hook but there are other
girls who do modeling as their
profession full-time and they're still
told that they're not fit enough you
know there's been many times in my life
where I've been I'm really uncomfortable
positions and I don't think those would
happen nowadays and in fact actually
last year I was on set and someone tried
some inappropriate things and I went
back to my agent and it was stopped
immediately but had I said that two
three years ago I doubt anything would
have happened
I remember going on a casting once and
this guy had made me feel really really
uncomfortable previously and I said to
my agent I actually don't want to go on
this casting because this guy was really
weird with me he's like tucking my hair
behind my ear touching my face like
telling me all this that really weird
sexual an appropriate stuff and then so
I said to my agent I actually don't want
to go on this casting again with him and
they said well you know he could make
you could make your career so I think
you should go and this casting was at
his apartment so you're putting yourself
in these situations that are really
really dangerous I think I don't think
that would happen now what are the most
amazing things you're doing now is
you're putting this whole empowering
ethos that you've created here that
you've had in your book that you've
shown on social media and you
into a beauty business called squish
what made you want to put that
empowerment into a beauty business back
in 2016 I was a becoming my sin disorder
it's a nice setup for charity in America
called the or woman project and we were
one of the first people to create unfold
shopped images now that ideas you know
it's happening quite a lot I even did
you know what glamour I did that on
photo shopped so we want the first
people to release these images and then
since then especially in the US it's
been it's quite prevalent now to have
all this diversity and you know women of
all different shapes sizes and colors it
actually wasn't back in like early 2016
was in so I always knew that if
everyone's going to set up a business I
was always gonna bring that with me
because I truly believe that people want
to see women of all shapes sizes and
colors who they can relate to you they
can also aspire to so it's great now
that you've got these agencies who've
got girls like every different shape
size and color because it allows girls
to dream that allows them to feel that
they can relate and I don't think things
like acne and cellulite and stretch
marks are necessarily bad things I think
we've always thought we have to
photoshop them out and women have to be
this like super smooth super perfect
human beings but actually showing a bit
of cellulite isn't going to detract
someone I don't think or deter someone
from buying a product it just isn't you
a bit on your own journey with acne
haven't you yes what's happen like for
you I went on like hormonal
contraceptives my skin wasn't that bad
when I was about nineteen twenty and I
decided to go in it and that's what
actually really affected my skin I never
had really bad skin before that maybe a
couple of sports as a teenager yeah I've
been really conscious about that and I
know how many other girls really
struggle with it and it doesn't make you
feel great
but what would you want to say to
someone who either feels they're
suffering from a dull acne and it's
really racking their confidence there's
there's so over consumed by their body
image or they are having to deal with
sexist pigs let's call them what they
are a few words think of a few more
words
that's a PG shave what would you want to
say to that girl or guy who's suffering
with those kind of things your image
isn't everything I know that we live in
a very image especially out of Instagram
a very image driven
society and culture and I do understand
there is a lot of like a ton of pressure
to look a certain way but we're also in
a part of time where unlike with me and
you were young we can actually choose
who you want to follow and we can choose
the images we want to see there's going
to be images that make you feel bad and
I matter where you look but if someone
makes you feel bad in social media
unfollow it because we spend so much
time on our phones just get rid of the
people that make you feel bad start
following people who don't look like you
and who maybe have a bit of a different
voice to you but who can lift you up and
make you feel empowered and you know
what like if acne is a really big
problem in your life there are
medications you can go on there are
creams you should go on it should
certainly should not make you feel
embarrassed to leave the house do you
feel empowered I feel empowered babes I
say holiday I'm ready to take on that
day born ready for more empowering
videos like this with such people as
Charlie Howard make sure you subscribe
to the glamour UK channels now and we'll
see you in two weeks for the next
episode of glamour and filtered with me
Josh Smith